[Musica]
ma li altre rivoluzioni sono necessarie
affinché la rivoluzione tecnologica e
digitale possa compiersi in futuro per
provare a rispondere a questa domanda
proviamo a immaginarlo insieme questo
futuro non distante qui vicino
proviamo immaginare la sicilia nel 2040
ho fatto un po di conti non con le
versioni dei nostri telefoni avremo
l'iphone 20 avremo delle stampanti 3d a
casa con cui stampare oggetti
se saremo autonomi o addirittura
potremmo stamparci del cibo chissà come
sarà nostra mobilità con queste vetture
connesse anche loro
e naturalmente le connessioni saranno
velocissimi a disposizione di tutti
saremo collegati con il resto del mondo
o magari da un ponte di ferro di cemento
ma da un ponte digitale è vero quando
parliamo di futuro pensiamo sempre a un
connotato molto molto positivo ed è
giusto che sia così però io credo che il
nostro futuro abbia anche delle
incognite dei problemi qualcosa dobbiamo
provare a risolvere
e ce n'è uno in particolare tra i tanti
che mi sta molto a cuore perché vedete
nel 2040 tutti gli studi dicono che il
nostro paese l'italia avrà circa la
stessa popolazione che adesso giusto un
poco di più ma il fenomeno spiacevole è
che il nord avrà un po più di abitanti
mentre soggiorno e la sicilia nera molti
di meno e questo perché ci sono poche
opportunità ed è un fenomeno che già
adesso in atto
tanti dei nostri giovani non lo
conosciamo con questa triste frase della
fuga dei cervelli sono costretti ad
andare via
badate bene io sono molto d'accordo al
fatto che i giovani possono avere delle
esperienze fuori
preferisco chiamarla rete di cervelli
però è anche molto importante che queste
persone possano tornare poi anche nella
nostra sicilia
e allora per provare a combattere questo
problema
credo che sia necessario che nonno tutti
interveniamo anche perché se no potremmo
trovarci in un grandissimo paradosso
quello di una sicilia piena di
opportunità ma sempre più vuota
io nella sicilia così non vorrei
assolutamente trovarmi
voglio fare qualcosa per trovare
evitarlo ma cosa questo è sicuramente
solo uno dei nostri tanti problemi e ha
sicuramente molte cause ma vorrei
concentrarmi su una quella che io penso
che sia più importante e voglio citare
libero e una frase molto molto
importante di tomasi di lampedusa in
sicilia non importa far male o far bene
il peccato che noi siciliani non
perdoniamo mai è semplicemente quello di
fare
e con questa credo che sia una purtroppo
delle nostre caratteristiche negative ne
abbiamo tante positive ma questa ce
l'abbiamo
se continuiamo a lottare per qualcosa di
piccolo e non costruiamo qualcosa di più
grande se continuiamo a essere
individualisti se non sopportiamo chi fa
ci ritroveremo con quel problema che vi
ho detto e con tanti altri e allora
quali sono le altre evoluzioni che
servono prima di quella tecnologica e
digitale
io credo che serva una rivoluzione
culturale
proprio per risolvere quel problema è
visto che io mi occupo di impresa di
innovazione proverò a guardarla da
questo punto di vista e sapete ci ho
riflettuto e credo che in realtà fare
una rivoluzione e fare impresa è quasi
la stessa cosa perché hanno tantissime
cose in comune innanzitutto fare impresa
è di per sé un piccolo grande atto
rivoluzionario e poi imprese
l'evoluzione hanno tante cose in comune
il rischio l'opportunità sacrificio e il
coraggio e allora proviamo a immaginare
che fare impresa non può essere
possibile e quindi se fare una
rivoluzione è necessario fare impresa è
quantomeno opportuno in questo momento
storico
anzi voglio dirvi di più secondo me fare
impresa e sexy e il momento giusto
c'è un mondo lì fuori che inizia a fare
il tifo per chi vuole fare impresa c'è
un quadro normativo che migliora e ci
sono tantissime imprese che stanno
nascendo e per darvi una testimonianza
di questo lo voglio fare nel modo più
sexy possibile i numeri questi numeri
rappresentano quadro nel nostro paese in
questo momento ci sono più di 6.500
start up innovative che nascono per
risolvere problemi ci sono più di 9.000
persone a cui stanno dando lavoro
ma il dato più bello di tutti è quello
ci sono più di 25 mila soci di queste
start up
perché sapete l'impresa e le rivoluzioni
non si fanno da soli si fanno insieme
noi di solito siamo abbastanza di
rigoristi invece nelle nuove imprese no
se condivide si fa tutto insieme e ci
hanno generato un fatturato nel 2015 di
più di mezzo miliardo di euro
immaginate quanto sarà più grande e
questo numero a fine del 2016 visto che
continuano a crescere a un ritmo
incessante giorno dopo giorno mese dopo
mese e quindi certo non possono essere
soltanto questi numeri a convincervi
l'idea di fare un'impresa matura nel
tempo ci vuole un'idea ci vuole un team
però non è che l'unica strada quella di
fare impresa
io vi consiglio di farlo sperimentato lo
è un qualcosa che può davvero cambiarmi
la vita però l'esortazione fate impresa
o la rivoluzione e se volete fate la
vostra o altrimenti aiutate chi la sta
già facendo perché ce ne sono tantissime
persone impegnate nelle loro sfide nelle
loro imprese nelle loro piccole grandi
rivoluzioni e allora voglio raccontarvi
quelle più belle che ho incontrato in
sicilia in questi in questi anni
la prima è la summer school di libera
associazione nomi e numeri contro le
mafie che ogni anno siamo il fuoco alle
pendici dell'etna il mio amico umberto
di maggio organizza e dove ragazzi da
tutta italia si incontrano utilizzando
proprio la metà dell'impresa
dell'innovazione per provare a risolvere
problemi basati su valori molto forti ma
pensando che proprio attraverso
l'impresa può essere possibile
bene questa è innovazione innovazione
sociale
un altro caso quindi ci siamo a favara
dove andrea e fiorinda a farmi fare un a
favara
avete sentito parlare diciamo dal loro
sogno dalla loro passione per la
diffusione della cultura dell'altro
dell'arte hanno creato un centro di
contaminazione culturale dove anche più
piccoli trovano spazio che alla fine si
è trasformato in un impresa sia
un'impresa perché da lavoro delle
persone crea un impatto un valore nel
territorio cresce da un'opportunità una
speranza
questa innovazione culturale e poi quel
catania abbiamo anche una casa
dell'innovazione si chiama v.cap dove
tantissimi ragazzi
a fare impresa lavorano insieme le loro
imprese sono un qualcosa di fantastico
ognuno di loro
meriterebbe di essere qui su questo
palco a raccontare quello che stanno
facendo
a raccontare il loro sogno e come
attraverso la risoluzione di un problema
provano a rendere un po questo mondo
migliore e questa è sicuramente
innovazione tecnologica e bellissimo
come questi luoghi
alla fine di innovazione sociale
culturale o tecnologica in realtà fanno
di tutti questi tre aspettino loro il
loro valore fondamentale
ma ci sono anche delle cose in cui mi
sono impegnato in prima persona perché
per risolvere quel problema di cui avevo
parlato credo che dobbiamo fare tutti un
pezzettino e questi sono quelli che ho
deciso di fare io
questo è il progetto che noi facciamo
con le scuole qui in sicilia di
diffusione della cultura d'impresa
sapete io sono diventato imprenditore e
propria scuola e quindi forse per questo
motivo credo che diffondere la cultura
d'impresa scuola sia importantissimo in
questi anni più di 50 istituti in
sicilia più di 150 progetti di impresa
dei ragazzi che frequentano le scuole
superiori e ne abbiamo coinvolti più di
2500 perché l'imprenditorialità a scuola
non è importante solo perché questi
ragazzi possano diventare imprenditori
ma importante perché l'imprenditore è
una metodologia è un'attitudine un modo
di pensare
l'imprenditore di imprenditorialità ti
aiuta a risolvere i problemi a pensare
che il cambiamento è una cosa positiva
vogliamo trasmettere questo tipo di
valori e se è vero che il futuro di un
paese e quindi anche della nostra
regione si costruisce a partire dai
banchi di scuola fare questo lavoro
questo lavoro di volontariato a scuola è
estremamente importante
e i risultati cc rincorro mai sono di
grandissimo interesse e poi per me è
bellissimo supportare le start up in
questi anni l'ho fatto alcune volte però
la storia più bella è quella di adriano
ed enrica d ora di fiber loro
trasformano dagli scarti degli agrumi e
creano tessuti è un grande sogno quando
qualche anno fa ho deciso di aiutarle ed
investire anche se il progetto è
bellissimo nome ne rendete conto non ho
investito sul progetto ma su di loro
perché il loro sogno la loro forza loro
determinazione e era un qualcosa di
travo
niente e ti accorgi che cerchi di dare
la tua esperienza il tuo supporto magari
anche un po di soldi un po di tempo in
realtà da un'esperienza del genere in
paris tantissimo perché anche se la mia
impresa soltanto qualche anno in più di
quella di aderire ed enrica anch'io ho
tantissimo da imparare da loro
e questa è una cosa che potrebbero fare
tutte le imprese se ci pensate innovare
aiutando chi vuole creare 11 impresa e
creando una contaminazione positiva e
con un'altra donna invece ho deciso di
fare una società sarà molto attiva nel
settore dell'innovazione nell'ambito del
food insieme abbiamo creato questo
ecosistema sul sito del futures food
dove ogni anno ospitiamo ragazzi da
tutta europa dall america da varie parti
del mondo che ci aiutano a innovare uno
dei settori in cui siamo leader quelli
del food con le loro idee e la loro
determinazione loro talenti guardandoci
dall'esterno è un ambiente
multiculturale che vedete in questa foto
dove sono rappresentati tantissimi paesi
e quest'anno che abbiamo avuti anche qui
in sicilia è una bellissima summer
school è però i talenti così come
l'intelligenza sono equamente
distribuiti dal mondo del mondo e quindi
non vengono soltanto nell'america
dall'europa dall'asia ma vengono anche
da altri posti anche dall'africa ci sono
dei talenti che possono davvero cambiare
le cose hanno la voglia di cambiare le
cose di cambiare tutto perché non hanno
niente e così quando qualche settimana
fa ho conosciuto questo ragazzo
straordinario chris che all'idea di
aiutare i migranti a usare al meglio le
tecnologie per formarsi per migliorarsi
e anche per diventare imprenditori e ho
deciso di aiutarlo di supportarlo perché
la nostra piccola azione di ognuno di
noi quando una nuova impresa nasce
quando nuovo sogno nasce può aiutare
davvero a contribuire a cambiare le cose
e quindi abbiamo visto come tante storie
tante storie che stanno cadendo proprio
adesso utilizzano l'innovazione la
tecnologia per provare a cambiare le
cose quindi a quella domanda che c'era
all'inizio io provo a dare una risposta
ovvero l'innovazione salverà
ma il sud secondo me no l'innovazione
non salverà il sud perché la tecnologia
digitale sono solo uno strumento il sud
lo salveranno le persone utilizzando
questi strumenti ma con la voglia di
farlo lo dicevamo prima fare e quindi io
credo che solo le persone possono fare
questa differenza solo le persone
possono salvare e migliorare il nostro
sud
queste persone siamo noi possiamo farlo
solo noi insieme
[Applauso]